sulfuric acid raining from the sky epic
dust storms raging for months on end and
giant hurricanes that could swallow
earth whole if you think earth has some
bad weather think again
mercury has little to no atmosphere and
therefore no real weather to speak of
but you would feel the full brunt from
the most powerful storms in our solar
system called coronal mass ejections
these explosive storms form on the Sun
and bathe mercury surface and
high-energy radiation so if the lack of
oxygen and extreme temperatures don't
kill you the radiations certainly will
this isn't as much of a problem on Venus
however after all the entire planet is
covered with clouds bad news is they're
toxic
these clouds rain sulfuric acid that's
so corrosive it would eat through your
skin on contact on Mars the surface is
rocky and desert like so wind can stir
up loose soil creating giant dust devils
twice the height of Mount Everest but
that's nothing compared to the dust
storms that sometimes engulf the entire
planet for months at a time and the
weather on Jupiter isn't any better of
course there's the Great Red Spot a
hurricane like storm that's been raging
for at least 300 years but there's
another storm on Jupiter that's equally
powerful with wind speeds twice as fast
as a category 5 hurricane its name is
oval ba otherwise known as The Little
Red Spot but it's hardly little it's
actually about the size of Earth and
it's been growing in size since
astronomers discovered it in 2000 next
door is a weather phenomenon that's even
larger Saturn's North Pole harbors a
giant jet stream called the hexagon each
of its six distinct sides are larger
than earth itself
and at its center is a massive rotating
cloud system that's 50 times larger than
the average eye of a hurricane on earth
moving right along
next up Uranus if you look at its tilt
you'll notice that Uranus spins on its
side which makes its seasons more
extreme than anywhere else in the solar
system for example wintertime has no
sunlight and because Uranus is so far
from the Sun winter lasts the equivalent
of 21 earth years that's 21 years with
temperatures that can reach as low as
negative 216 degrees Celsius last but
not least is Neptune you'll want to pack
a windbreaker for this visit nicknamed
the windiest planet Neptune strongest
winds can exceed 1930 km/h that's one
and a half times the speed of sound on
earth and fast enough to fly from New
York to Los Angeles in just two point
three hours
so maybe the acid rain towering dust
devils and super-fast winds make our
planet's weather look a little nicer not
too hot not too cold not too windy just
right